I am going to Mandalore.
There's nothing left.
Go home.
And me?
A clan
of two
but you
have removed your helmet.
And you are a mandalorian.
No more
your cult.
Fractured our people.
Where were you then?
Did you think your dad
was the only Mandalorian?
season for you. I've written it already.
We have to know where
we're going to tell a fully formed story.
So we had mapped it out, Dave and I.
And then. And slowly
you just write each episode.
So I was writing it during post-production
and that because all of it
has to feel like a continuation
and one one full story,
and then he's doing Ahsoka,
which I'm producing with him,
but he's the, he's
the writer showrunner on that.
And so to understand what's happening
on other shows or even Skeleton
Crew all take place in the same Star Wars
time period.
So there's a lot more things
that we have to do
to keep in mind and stuff
that we've built up
to from previous seasons
of The Mandalorian as well.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This is the way they released New
Mandalorian Season three trailer footage.
We'll break it down.
We also have a teaser
for The Mandalorian Season four.
Like the clip I put at the beginning
that is literally Jon Favreau talking
about the Mandalorian season four all.
Explain what's going on with that,
because we haven't even gotten Season
three yet
and they're talking about season four.
So I'll explain what kind of plot
they're going to be covering by the time
we get to season four.
Rosario Dawson
also revealed a bunch of details
about the Ahsoka episodes coming later
this year.
I'll explain that too,
if you're brand new to the channel.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
But the new footage is a bo-katan
trying to discourage
Mando from going back to the planet
Mandalore
basically telling him the exact
opposite of what the armor is telling him
he has to do in order to regain his honor
and become a true mandalorian again.
The whole thing here is that Bo-Katan
basically believes the exact opposite
of what the armor believes in,
and they're like diametric opposite.
Sitting on Mando shoulders his best armor
shoulders telling him what to do with him
having to choose a path.
He's basically being given similar choices
to the same vibe of the choices
is what Grogu who was given by Luke
Skywalker like which path are you
choosing the best armor or Yoda's
light saber, The Path of the Jedi
or the path of the Mandalorians grow
to essentially chose the mando.
Like going back to the mando over
choosing Luke Skywalker in the Jedi
training,
he'll continue to train in the force.
Jon Favreau was pretty clear about that.
Like, Oh no, he's gotten way more powerful
since the end of the book of Boba Fett,
and there has been a time jump
since the end of Book of Boba Fett
when Mando Season three picks up.
The way he described that,
he said there's been enough time for Grogu
to become even more powerful.
So all the force abilities
that you saw Grogu
using at the end of the book of Boba Fett,
he'll be way more powerful than that,
but he's still ramping up.
This is still very early days for Grogu,
who obviously he's going to become much,
much more powerful in his lifetime.
But just because he's
not with Luke Skywalker doing traditional
Jedi training doesn't mean
that he's not training in the force.
In the trailers, when Bo-Katan says
there's nothing left there for you,
there is no more home.
She's talking about the slag that the
Empire turned the planet Mandalore into.
You see some of the wreckage of their
Dome city or one of their dome cities.
That's meant to be the same one
that we saw during the Clone Wars.
The reason they had a dome city
is because they'd already bombed the hell
out of their planet in previous wars
from thousands and thousands of years ago.
The dome was because the planet itself
wasn't that habitable to begin with.
But what wound up happening
is that during the events
of the original trilogy,
the Empire basically bombed
the hell out of it.
They call that the Great Purge
because Bo-Katan,
who was leading them at that point
because she had the Darksaber,
they covered that
during the events of the rebel series.
She united the remaining Mandalorian
factions at the end of the Rebel series,
and it seemed like a big rallying
cry for them.
Like, Yeah,
they're going to be awesome now.
But during the events
of the original trilogy,
the Emperor wanted them to capitulate like
he wanted the Mandalorians to serve him,
and they wouldn't do
that. Bo-Katan turned him down.
So in retaliation for that,
he had Moff Gideon, who was working
with the Imperial Security Bureau.
We saw their group during the Andor
series.
Moff Gideon came from the Imperial
Security Bureau before he became a mob.
He had them orchestrate
the great Purge of Mandalore,
where he basically bombed the entire
planet, trying to kill all of them.
While that was happening,
it sounds like Moff Gideon
pilfered the planet
for everything that he could
because the Emperor
also wanted their beskar.
So essentially the bird's grand plan for
the Mandalorians was to take their beskar
their troops, their weapons,
so he could make stronger troopers.
Which moff Gideon Great Admiral Thrawn
are now trying to complete in present day.
They cover that
during the first couple of seasons.
The reason why Beskar was so rare
is because the Empire had stolen
most of their beskar from the planet.
But it also gets into the whole idea
of the grogu
cloning storyline during the first couple
of seasons in the idea that the Emperor
wanted to create stronger troopers
using cloning techniques in the force.
So you imagine them combining
all those ideas with the best armor
and the mandalorians weapons
they're fighting techniques
they would basically made invincible
clone troopers that are force sensitive.
I think that was the idea
with the dark troopers during season two.
The whole idea that the empire
Moff Gideon great.
Admiral
Thrawn were slowly trying to create more
and more powerful troopers
that were easier for them to control.
And ultimately
it was easier for them to control either
robots, cyborgs or clones
than it is for regular troopers.
They also confirmed
that they're going to answer definitively
who saved Grogu
Who at the Jedi Temple during Order 66.
And that's what all these new Order 66
flashbacks are for him.
The most likely candidate so far
that we've seen are the Jedi librarians,
who we've already seen in flashbacks.
Probably not Mace Windu,
because the Star Wars people
have actually joked about this way
too much recently, losing his arm, falling
from that high of a height,
and then dragging his way to the Jedi
temple to continue
trying to save all these other Jedi.
And again, Skywalker is a
maybe like saving Grogu himself, basically
allowing him to escape,
not purposely saving him,
but just allowing him to get away.
Yoda was on Kashyyk during Order 66,
so it wasn't him.
Yaddle was killed by Count Dooku
during the events of Attack of the Clones.
So it wasn't her.
And now one of my leading theory
is after the events
of the Obi-Wan Kenobi episodes
is that it could have been Quinlan Vos.
He was namedrop during the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series is a Jedi
who had escaped Order 66.
And ever since then, like he'd
been about ten years
since Revenge of the Sith,
when Obi-Wan Kenobi picks up.
That whole time, he'd
been helping other force
sensitive people in the Underground Space
Railroad.
Basically avoid capture by Darth
Vader, the Emperor in the inquisitors.
And that's basically
what happened with Grogu, who,
like he basically went into hiding
in the outer
rim using that same type of underground
railroad that the Jedi were using.
But it seems like one of the main
goals of season three is to have Mando
regain his honor,
like he'll go back to the planet Mandalore
and fulfill the requirements of the armor,
but then slowly choose his own path
because Bo-Katan is also yelling
in his ear
about what he needs
to be doing with the Darksaber
rallying their people so that they can
fight the remnants of the Empire.
Grand Admiral Thrawn
Moff Gideon retake the planet.
So there's a bunch of stuff on his
to do list during season three
talking about the events of season four.
So here's where we get to the season
four plot.
Mando will probably have
already regained his honor.
Like I said, they'll probably take care
of that during season three.
He'll still probably have the Darksaber.
So both factions, the Mandalorians
Bo-Katan faction in the Armor's faction
will be more willing to follow him.
Grogu will be way more powerful,
like he'll continue to get more powerful
through season three
and they'll probably like a small time
jump between season
three and season four again,
just because they've been doing that
the past couple of seasons
will probably already have met Grand
Admiral Thrawn, either like a teaser
at the end of the Mandalorian Season three
and more fully during the Ahsoka series.
Or they'll just wait for the Ahsoka series
to show him on screen
and we'll know more about his grand plan
to take control of the galaxy
again under a new empire
that they're trying to form.
Like I said, the overarching plot
with Grand Admiral Thrawn seems like
they're trying to do a version of the Heir
to the Empire trilogy,
like the original Thrawn trilogy, but
in this time period of the Mandalorian.
So if you've read those novels,
something similar to that,
like some of the storylines
from that adapted
with different characters, Moff
Gideon is supposed to return in force,
so he'll probably be more powerful again
in season four with Grand Admiral Thrawn.
They also teased that he would have
Mandalorian inspired armor upgrades.
So the whole idea is that
he has this very Darth
Vader inspired armor in the first couple
of seasons during season three.
I believe he's supposed to debut
some more Mandalorian Beskar
inspired Armor Designs.
I think the vibe of that will be closer
to the Mandalorian Super Commandos.
Those were initially the ones that served
Darth Maul the Mandalorians and sided
with Darth Maul and then later wound up
serving the Emperor.
And it sounds like they plan to release
season four at the end of next year
because they're going to start
filming it in October this year,
which gives them more than enough time
to finish the season
before the end of next year,
which is great,
which means we don't have to wait
like two years
before we get the next season.
There are rumors that they're filming
the book of Boba Fett Season two
because they're building a new version
of his ship, The Slave One and his armor.
But they could just be building
that for the Mandalorian Season four.
Rosario Dawson
also teased that the Ahsoka series release
date is going to be in the fall,
which is basically
any time between September
and the end of the year.
She was talking about fall
in the United States.
I'm excited.
I'm nervous about it.
And also just for your character, Ahsoka.
Yeah, that's
going to probably come out in the fall.
The past several months,
they've been saying
that the Skeleton Crew series,
which also takes place in the same time
period Jon
Favreau
talked about at the beginning of this clip
that stars
Jude Law and a bunch of other characters
in a different part of the galaxy,
like those characters won't show up
during The Mandalorian Season
three before they show up in the Skeleton
Crew series.
They've been saying that that's
going to release at the very end of 2023
this year,
but they could always wind up
delaying that
just because they made
a couple schedule changes
with the way that Marvel and Star Wars
people release their series
so they could wait
till the end of the year
to release the Ahsoka episodes,
or they could release that
in like September or October
and get all eight episodes of that out
and then release Skeleton
Crew around the same time
they started releasing the book of Boba
Fett Season one.
Either way, there's going to be
a bunch of Star Wars stuff happening
towards the end of this year,
and there will be multiple seasons
of the Ahsoka series.
Like it'll run for like three, four,
hopefully five or more seasons.
They're also supposed to announce what
the next Star Wars movie is going to be,
and that's supposed to come out in 2025
at the end of 2025.
A lot of that will get announced around
Star Wars Day this year.
I think that's when we're going
to get the first Ahsoka trailer as well.
I've actually already done a video
on the leaked trailer that they released.
You can click here to learn about that
and click here for that
opening scene from The Mandalorian Season
three Episode one.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.